[Music]
ready and action
there she is a pride and joy the
Millennium Falcon being on the Falcon is
pretty thrilling and it's also really
familiar so in a way you're kind of puts
you at ease because you know the space
you know the hollow chess table walking
around the Millennium Falcon like I
didn't have to do any research I didn't
have to read about it that knowledge is
in my head already
you might wanna buckle up baby I think
the amazing thing about this movie is
actually how little CGI there was
they've introduced this rig so it feels
like you're flying we're actually
looking at a projected version of space
it was the Disneyworld ride that only we
had to fast pass to and it was just
unbelievable how detailed it all was
that makes it so much easier to try to
fight for your life while you're
controlling this big spaceship it is so
much fun to see how these sets are
designed because even though you know
digital technology certainly factors
into capturing the galaxy it's still
very important that these vehicles these
props the Falcon as much as possible is
something you can shoot in camera
and I think you feel like you're on this
ride alongside Han
[Applause]
you